hola ya el momento de conocer las
principales noticias en materia
económica de américa latina y del resto
del mundo y por eso nos acompaña por
supuesto nuestra compañera daniela
hablando muy buenas noches
daniela comenzamos con noticias de
américa latina- no porque los
distribuidores de lo que es gas propano
en ciudad de méxico se declararon en
huelga aquí pasó porque hola santiago
pues lo hacen dos días después de que el
gobierno nacional impusiera controles de
precios al combustible la medida ya
había sido criticada por el regulador
antimonopolio que aseguró que esto
podría tener consecuencias no deseadas
como por ejemplo la escasez de glp
algunos camiones de distribución
bloquearon entradas a los centros de
acopio de combustible para protestar
porque dicen que sus ganancias se van a
ver afectadas pues la mayoría de ellos
son privados pero el presidente andrés
manuel lópez obrador ha dicho que ella
se infla en sus márgenes de ganancias a
costa de los usuarios y que una empresa
pública importaría y vendería este gas
más barato
santiago el glp o gas licuado de
petróleo lo utiliza cada día el 70% de
los mexicanos
y las entregas a domicilio han llegado a
duplicar su precio en ciertas áreas
durante el último año de pandemia vamos
ahora egipto el presidente anunció que
se van a disminuir los subsidios al pan
claro que si santiago mire la historia
subir los precios del pan en el mayor
importador de trigo del mundo es la más
reciente de una serie de medidas de
austeridad anunciadas por el gobierno
que dice que este producto lleva 30 años
subsidiado aunque no deja de ser una
medida bastante impopular recordemos en
1977 hubo protestas en lo que se conoció
como el levantamiento del pan cuando el
presidente de ese entonces intentó subir
el precio ahora veamos un ejemplo que no
lo pongo yo lo pone el mismo presidente
abdel fattah al cis y 20 piezas de pan
subsidiado cuestan una libra egipcia que
equivale a 6 centavos de dólar con ese
mismo dinero dice el mandatario egipcio
se compra una o máximo dos piezas de pan
en el mercado normal escuchemos
al día de la q asumiré la
responsabilidad de cambiar esta
situación frente a mi país y mi pueblo
es increíble que proporcionemos 20
barras de pan por el mismo precio de un
solo cigarrillo lo digo en vivo por
televisión a todos los egipcios esto
tiene que terminar
necesitamos 8 mil millones de libras
egipcias para proporcionar comida a
nuestros estudiantes y no tenemos el
dinero bueno vamos ahora a ecuador donde
entró en vigencia la reforma arancelaria
de qué se trata santiago el gobierno de
guillermo lasso asegura que eliminó un
total de 180 millones de dólares en
aranceles de un total de 670 y 667
subpartidas el ministerio de producción
especificó que quedarán exentos de
gravámenes por ejemplo los computadores
y sus equipos así como los automóviles
repuestos y máquinas y también las
herramientas agrícolas
por su parte bajarán del 25% al 5 por
ciento los aranceles de las cámaras
digitales y del 30 al 10% los de las
bicicletas sólo por mencionar algunos de
los ejemplos hablemos ahora
debut en la bolsa vamos a hablar de la
empresa de victoria secret no que se
estrenó en lo que es la bolsa pero lo
hizo como empresa independiente cómo es
esto
mire esta empresa y su división pink se
separaron oficialmente de su casa matriz
que se llama el brand y de paso de la
reconocida basa en body works otra de
sus marcas de esta manera tanto la firma
de lencería como la de productos de
cuidado personal comienzan a seguir su
camino como independiente es una de la
otra con este divorcio victoria secret
ahí quedó cotizando solita en la bolsa
de nueva york desde este martes y en
apenas una jornada se disparó en más del
26 por ciento hasta los 58 dólares
victoria secrets lleva más de un año en
una especie de limbo empresarial se han
buscado diferentes estrategias incluida
una posible venta debido a que ha tenido
bastantes dificultades financieras bueno
vamos a abordar con los indicadores del
día que dicen wall street de cerró en
positivo y los optimistas inversores
llevaron al índice standard and poor's a
un nuevo máximo histórico por su parte
robin
qué es una aplicación para
inversionistas principiantes que se hizo
muy famosa por el caso gamestop revirtió
su próximo resultado de hace pocos días
cuando se lanzó a bolsa y este martes se
disparó en 24 por ciento y en américa
latina' la brasileña raíz en que es
líder mundial en la producción de
biocombustibles salió a bolsa de sao
paulo y captó 1.300 millones de dólares
muchísimas gracias a de vida por ésta
completísima crónica económica de
nuestra audiencia la invitamos a
continuar informando se en el resto de
nuestra programación y por supuesto
también en france24 punto com sigan con
nosotros
[Música]